all right Kevin is in Seattle hi Kevin
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up so I am
working through baby step two and just
started working for a B sub-2 and I
currently am in school about halfway
done and I have about 22,000 in student
loan debt I'm wondering a couple things
one do I stop school until I can pay for
it - that way I'm not continuing with
the student loan debt or do I drop
school altogether it's IET management
okay what do you do for a living
IT management they pay for it the
organization on that is a non-profit and
so there's lots of there's lots of
experience but they don't have the
resources for that I have been going
towards my career management
I make total I make 67 in total about 75
with my wife mmm okay I don't you have
22,000 student loan debt what other that
do you have a grand total it's about a
thousand start one hundred with my wife
student loan debt and medical bills car
payments
let's do in your car one car I owe about
three thousand and then the other car I
owe about 15 okay there it is okay
I want to tighten up my budget and say I
really can't make much progress on my
baby step two but I'm gonna finish my
degree what's it going to cost to finish
the degree it would cost probably
between another ten to fifteen it's an
online school and I can you make seventy
five thousand dollars a year if you pay
minimum payments on everything and get
on a beans and rice budget stay out of
restaurants you can catch flow the
balance of your education
not gonna make any progress on your debt
while you're doing that but you can
finish your education in which case your
income ought to go up twenty thirty
thousand bucks when you finish it we're
gonna have to leave that job you know
that yeah yeah okay at some point I mean
you got to sign it but if you're going
to finish this degree in order to
further your career it's not gonna be at
that place they can't afford you once
you've gotten this degree but 15,000
bucks finish it flow it out man you
stopped paying extra on everything cash
flow it out you don't to borrow more you
can do it but you do if you're borrowing
more in order to keep doing baby step
two is dead snowballing then you're just
borrowing money to debt snowball that's
dog chasing his tail and don't need to
do that so just let it sit there and
tread water till you get out of school
and then hammer it this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]